they say that for everything there is a
season
but tried telling that to a farmer niger
this year
normally hassam's millet harvest will
yield enough to feed his family for a
year but this time it will only last
three months
you say
if the rainy season is good
the graft is good like this
but now it's small like this
drought has caused crop failure
throughout the sahel
and the effects are already being felt
at the market nearby
millet prices have risen by 30
since the same time last year
even in the best of times poor education
and bad diet keep the beds full of
severely malnourished children at this
hospital nearby doso
the red means they may never reach their
full potential another generation
blighted by hunger
the devastated harvest has authorities
watching out for an increase in
admissions
nigeria struggles with some of the
highest rates in population growth and
poverty a drought like this year can set
many people over the edge from hunger
into starvation the last thing they need
is another hungry mouth to feed
no food
but that's exactly what is happening i
gon do in the end easy abdullah was
working as a garbage collector in libya
during the uprising he barely escaped
the lynch mob
he was evacuated by ship and then
airlifted back to niger he has five
children and his wife is in the hospital
now back home with no job he can't pay
her hospital bill much less finish the
house he was building with the
remittances he was sending from libya
hunger is forcing people to leave their
homes looking for work in nigeria benin
and the ivory coast
in this town only woman children and the
elderly remain
now even they have had enough
this woman says she has decided to go to
the capital miami to sell sand
it doesn't have to be this way just a
few kilometers away in gabi malal koia
tomatoes are growing in the desert the
world food program paid these women with
food to reclaim a silted lake
now it provides water life and hope
but humanitarian organizations are
fighting the perception that places like
niger are basket cases that there's no
point in trying to help nobody's asking
the world food program for a free
handout in niger
nobody not the government not the local
authorities and certainly not the women
in the community they're not asking us
for a free handout they're asking us for
some assistance so that they can stay in
their homes in their villages work in
their fields maintain their families
and keep their life going
niger's future begins and ends here
meals given to these children at school
ensures that they can concentrate on
learning instead of their hungry
stomachs
if tomatoes can flourish in the desert
then so can they
for the world food program i'm jonathan
dumont